[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut intérieur salut les terriens
bienvenue dans votre taux du samedi soir
bonsoir
c'est rien de choix avec nous ce soir un
robot jean-mi bolivie ne
servent à jean mi tu as eu de bons échos
de ta prestation de la semaine dernière
oui super on a même proposé la météo du
grand journal abc
avec jean mi ce soir michèle alliot
marie
michèle alliot-marie bonsoir
alors on dit en fait on dit mam voilà et
pour françois hollande on dit
lol très bien
bérengère qui a t'on soir
vous êtes notre newcomers de ce soir
vous êtes humoriste est l'un de vos
sketches les plus célèbres est un guide
est répartie aux mecs qui drague
lourdement j'avais dit quoi à nagui tout
à l'heure
christophe hondelatte
christophe hondelatte vous êtes notre
ticket ou de la semaine avec deux bonnes
nouvelles premièrement vous arrivez sur
bfm les soirs de week-end on s'en
réjouit et deuxièmement vous arrêté
votre carrière de chanteur revenons à
merde
et nagui
[Applaudissements]
encore une bonne nouvelle non seulement
nous trions trait sur france 2 avec deux
émissions quotidiennes mais vous arrivez
sur france inter tous les jours aux
heures pour la redevance on sait comment
je fais un chèque directement politique
comme d'ailleurs en p3 après le zapping
gaspard proust
nous accueillons notre terriens du
samedi 20 heures ce soir lorraine
atteinte de la maladie de charcot contre
laquelle les stars du monde entier
récolte de l'argent faisant le iceberg
est challenge voilà l'émission s'appelle
salut les terriens le robot s'appelle
jour me et le groupe les gréement de
fortune
[Musique]
alors navire bonsoir il est ici pour
nous faire une révélation étonnante tout
ce que l'on prédit que ça va sur vous et
fo en fait vous êtes blond vous n'êtes
suède vous appelez semaine et toutes ces
histoires d'égyptiens c'était un moyen
de bénéficier des places réservées aux
minorités la télévision c'est pas très
bien ce que vous avez
alors nagui en fait c'est ici ce soir
pour célébrer votre victoire au grand
jeu de france 2 tout le monde veut
prendre ma place
un jeu dans lequel des candidats comme
sophia aram bruno guillon laurent
ruquier se sont pourtant essayé le c'est
vous qui avez gagné vous tenez le coup
nagui vous animez deux jeux par jour sur
france 2 tout le monde veut prendre sa
place du lundi au dimanche à 12 heures
et n'oubliez pas les paroles du lundi au
vendredi à 18h50 alors compte tenu du
vieillissement
téléspectateurs de france 2 le jeu
s'appellera bientôt n'oubliez pas votre
prénom
[Applaudissements]
ça cartonne et sa rage ou
alors on parle du retour de que le
meilleur gagne ouais que vous animez en
1991 ça fait 23 ans c'est une émission
marty ça a marché
nom de zeus nabi quand on travaille
autant on gagne de l'argent
c'est vrai qu'à saint tropez vos bateaux
vous les appelez france 2 et france 4
ça serait une bonne idée le jour où
j'aurai des bateaux peut-être bah oui et
la maison vous la perdez la redevance
et puis à france inter
ce qu'il faut dire
c'est nagui à la maison quand il était
petit ses parents écoutent et france
inter france inter nagui s'est un petit
peu là la bande originale de votre
enfance n'avait radio france et la
première le premier contrat de travail
que j'ai ça compte quand même dans une
vie bien sûr c'était un dimanche
d'octobre 82 et où je rentrais à radio
france côte d'azur il y avait chantal
lauby il y avait bruno carette et c'est
bruno carette à qui j'ai demandé parce
qu'ils aident à télé sur nice côte
d'azur jeudi mais c'est génial de faire
date et comment on fait pour faire de la
télé et il me dit pour faire de la td il
y avait un petit accent pinoit recevoir
la télé il faut être moche et toi tu as
toutes les chances
alors on s'intéresse et la bande
originale de votre enfance et l'émission
s'appelle la bande originale c'est du
lundi au vendredi à 11 heures sur france
inter avec daniel morin michel cymes et
pierre lescure philippe labro et j corse
et nawa chris esquerre les laquais de
bouddha dit non il ya christophe
alévêque il ya alex vizorek 1 il fallait
que ce soit une bande moyenne 2 que ce
qu'elle soit la plus éclectique possible
il faut qu'il y ait le bougon il faut
qu'il y ait le sage il faut qu'il y ait
la féministe il faut qu'il y ait le
provocant l'idée de la banque c'est
original feu non c'est la bande
originale évidemment que le jeu de mots
et avec la bande autour de la table mais
c'est surtout la bo d'ajourner way alors
évidemment trois émissions parce que
c'est usant rares moments où on fait
plus qu'on dit
la santé des enfants quel animateur
suceurs de sang conseils tels de mettre
sous vos cas l'animal j'ai dix
animateurs
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est horrible c'est que je sais
pourquoi mais que je peux bazire ah ben
non ah bah non
obama dont on pense qu'il a écrit alors
produite
alors fait beaucoup de choses mais oui
mais vous ne chantez pas non c'est pas
le cas de tous les élus
[Musique]
dj de retour
ça va
l'as rome
ici
il a composé pour le plaisir le prcg
c'est bien
attention didier
bogdanov philippe le sponsor sur mes
lunettes
je n'y vois plus très bien vous aurez
lunettes bérengère doit se voir alice
jacques martin
les formidables jacques martin c'est un
formidable vous êtes beaucoup moins
jeunes que ce que vous
plantez la remontée
papa
pays comment vous fait
danser pas d'un violent bozo seth gueko
quant aux joueurs s'étaient 512
attention didier
là c'est facile
sébastien
et ta gueule
ouais
c'est horrible ce jeu parce que soit tu
reconnais pas tu passe pour un con soit
tu reconnais et ils
vont compter dans le carré à la fin vous
me dirai qui a gagné que je puisse du
baiser les pieds didier
agathe à la gare
attention didier
oui a dit cris a dit y'a qu'à laisser ce
petit compromis
dommage
dès 11 heures je vous
j'aime aller
j'avais promis que vous baiser les pieds
la double
[Applaudissements]
je me regardais à la télé quand j'étais
petit j'allais venir un
jour et ramadi est fier de son coup
franc des bijoux voilà c'était la
personne
sur terre
à toute chute
[Musique]
ça
vous
[Musique]
bonsoir était un rebond soir était rien
nous sommes de retour sur terre toujours
en compagnie de michèle alliot marie
[Applaudissements]
je perds en gère
christophe hondelatte
la guide
et jean mi
est-ce que je peux chanter aussi claqué
avec korek file vickery djahel l'arctic
sun explique est passé
[Musique]
jean mi c'est dingue ça c'est du
playback tout tu senti une chanson à toi
la prochaine fois ils ont mis d'accord
et maintenant on passe à notre tt ou de
la semaine
et
[Applaudissements]
chan
je
christophe hondelatte re bonsoir repower
christophe tu étais où on ne voit plus
aux soirées
hors flash back après avoir quitté
faites entrer l'accusé de votre plein
gré ce qui nous a pas empêché de
critiquer votre remplaçante je le
regrette
au nom
trompeur sampler
[Applaudissements]
face
à cela qu'avez vous à dire à votre
remplaçant
alors après avoir quitté faites entrer
l'accusé de votre plein gré oui ce qui
nous a pas empêché de critiquer votre
remplace
[Musique]
après avoir quitté le 13 heures de
france 2 peu de temps avant le direct à
cause d'un article dans libération
[Musique]
après avoir quitté le plateau de on
n'est pas couché suite à une critique
d'audrey pulvar
[Musique]
après avoir quitté la rédaction de rtl
suite à une dispute avec votre assistant
après avoir quitté le plateau de tiers
disent oh
non mais c'est vrai sérieusement après
tout ça vous êtes un petit peu sortis
des des radars tu vas passage à vide
médiatique je crois qu'on pas de blague
règles je le reconnaît humblement je
suis passé en deuxième division mais
j'ai continué à jouer et là après tout
ça
christophe vous avez opéré une
reconversion étonnante dans le cirque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que sir que par leur histoire leur
note baisser les siens en face aux
grains d'après ce qu'ils gagnent de la
presse alors en fait non vous étiez pas
du tout au cirque pinder
reconverti dans des chansons signées
dans le coup à leur sauce une
interprétation abusive ouais j'ai choisi
un peu dit avoir un peu de liberté mende
rapport à l'idée que les gens se fonde
une carrière organise externe donc je me
donne les moyens de cette liberté ça a
été la chanson mais là dans les deux
trois ans qui viennent je me concentre à
nouveau sur ma carrière mais elle parce
que sinon sinon je vais finir à vendre
des tomates
j'en ai assez des chiens dans un cirque
voilà mais ça ne veut pas dire pas plus
tard qu'hier après midi j'ai répété près
de quatre heures avec avec mon pianiste
et je continue de jongler s'est pas fait
ça c'est ce qu'a dit pianiste
bon enfin non sérieusement à l'époque il
tient un peu dépressif c'est vrai oui
c'était du un médicament de ce fait le
lyrica le médicaments que vous prenez
contre votre mal au dos c'est l'époque
du cuir du latex des toilettes du grand
rex au des dons s'est pas tapé gueule
toi je rêve
cuir
et le lartet
et les toilettes
grand
passé la nuit hier vous
[Musique]
feat
[Applaudissements]
j'assume
non mais vous avez déclaré si c'était à
refaire je le referais pas donc oui
c'est je leur ferai pas comme je lé fais
là ouais j'ai été à l'époque très
accompagné par mon employeur auquel
j'étais en playlist sur rtl et c'est
donc et en même temps que finalement
cette aventure s'est mal terminée pour
eux et pour moi en même temps mais voilà
donc c'est bon c'était mal géré j'aurais
après tout mozart a jamais vendu un
indice de 100 go étant gentil
donc voilà donc après votre départ de
rtl ça a été un petit peu la traversée
du désert et a eu la web tv de yahoo
la chaîne
23-23 c'est le nombre de gens qui
regardent
jamais vu
quand on est au fond assez gourmande et
des gens de ce qu'ils ont dans les
tripes de moi je m'ennuie nulle part
après c'est toujours un peu frustrant
personne te regarde bon et bien eu 13ème
rue qui tient beaucoup plus regardées
j'avais fait on de la part en live
[Musique]
c'est marrant nanterre 5 enrichir
regarder je vais dans son jardin allez
je vais aller j'ai volé à bord d'un
alphajet de la patrouille de france j'ai
fait des tas de trucs en afrique du sud
au sein du sud en partie voire et là
christophe vous revenez dans la lumière
sur bfm c'est vrai qu'ils ont fait
signer une clause de non démission à
moins de deux heures du journal
fait je fais deux tranches d'info valeur
21h l'exercice classique du journal que
sincèrement je pensais ne jamais refaire
mais vous faites bien mais 22 minutes
qui est inquiet assez proche de ce que
je faisais déjà la radio qui est un talk
show d'un four ou quoi dérangère alors
ce qu'il faut dire si vous étiez dingue
de faites entrer l'accusé je crois que
pour vous c'était et moi je préférais
quand c'était christophe
le plus en vue
des vitrines
notre invité suivante c'est celle à qui
super nanny a tout piqué michèle
alliot-marie
[Applaudissements]
ya quelque chose
vous allez mieux qu'elle voit elle est
morte
alors michèle alliot marie il vous avez
l'un des plus beaux cv de la république
ministre des affaires étrangères me la
justice me de l'intérieur ministères
défense plus quelques secrétariat d'état
plus la présidence du rpr plus la vice
présidence de l'ump et tout ça sans
avoir été mise en examen bravo sarkozy
et qu'aujourd'hui des hommes politiques
des femmes politiques qui n'ont jamais
été mis en examen alors en même temps
tout abus de biens sociaux même pas un
petit enrichissement personnel même pas
un financement illégal bravo michel
[Musique]
alors vous êtes aujourd'hui
vice-président de l'ump député
européenne ça va financièrement
non parce que vous avez déclaré je vais
perdre de l'argent en allant au
parlement européen oui c'est ce que j'ai
voulu dire j'en ai bien petit peu assez
de voir des journalistes qui me disaient
mais vous allez au parlement européen
pour gagner de l'argent je leur ai
simplement dit une chose c'est que
auparavant c'est vrai par mes
conférences par un certain nombre de
choses je faisais mes revenus et des
supérieurs à ceux que j'ai aujourd'hui
comme parlementaires européens et que si
j'allais au parlement européen c'est
parce que j'ai une vraie conviction
alors vous y arrivez avec votre salaire
du parlement européen puisque rachida y
arrivait pourtant les dépensiers à
rachida
alors en parlant de rachida comment va
l'ump ça flingue pas trop
vrai qu'en politique tout le poignard
est le poison ouais ouais alors michèle
alliot-marie vous publié chez plon la
tentation totalitaire de la gauche alors
je fais le pitch attention la gauche est
en train de verrouiller le pouvoir à son
avantage et d'imposer son idéologie
notamment à l'école leur objectif c'est
de garder le pouvoir c'est ce que vous
appelez la tentation totalitaire
alors ça passe par quoi des nominations
dans les ministères les grandes
entreprises publiques évidemment
manipulation du découpage électoral
noyautage des cerveaux à l'école et même
dit vous le détournement de l'attention
médiatique écoutez tout homme qui a du
pouvoir et toute femme aussi un
d'ailleurs à a envie de le garder oui
dont le vrai problème c'est de savoir si
il va tout faire pour convaincre les
français ou bien s'il va laisser de côté
les règles démocratiques pour essayer de
se maintenir quoi qu'il arrive au
pouvoir et finalement je démontre à
travers des cas extrêmement précis et
extrêmement nombreux et bien que une
bonne partie de la gauche effectivement
non seulement mais ces hommes en place
mais également temps à changer un
certain nombre de règles du jeu tend
également à considérer que l'adversaire
est un ennemi est-ce que franchement
vous croyez qu'on peut parler de
tentations totalitaires dans un pays où
le présent à public ne sait même pas que
son ex publier un livre sur lui
et écoutez je pense que les précautions
qui ont été prises justement pour la
sortie de ce livre
montre que visiblement certains de se
méfier du risque de dire été pris dedans
pêcher la publication de ce livre tu
crois qu'il ya une tentation totalitaire
de la part de la gauche aujourd'hui en
france non franchement j'ai connu cela
après 80 il ya eu une vraie tentative de
voile à prendre le contrôle externe
aujourd'hui c'est chose n'existe pas
plus fou que sarkozy et nous avons gagné
notre indépendance depuis belle lurette
et il n'est pas question de revenir là
dessus et franchement je ne sais même
d'être optimiste comme ça moi j'ai
regardé un certain nombre de faits qui
s'accumulent je dis attention et c'est
pour ça que ça s'appelle la tentation je
n'ai pas nous sommes dans un pays
totalitaire mais je dis faisons
attention il ya d'autres pays aussi
qu'ils apparaissaient comme des pays
très démocratique où les gens ne
m'imaginais pas que ça puisse arriver et
où néanmoins et en europe même les
choses sont claires ça s'appelle la
tentation totalitaire de la gauche c'est
publié chez plon merci et on passe
maintenant à la question de jean mi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puis oui
t
vas-y gens me pose ta question au petit
je ne voulais pas déjà dresser me
conseiller pour des vacances en tunisie
y en a des tas d'adressent superbe la
tunisie est un pays superbe et les
tunisiens sont des gens extrêmement
tolérant et est formidable mon agent me
fait thierry qui m'a obligé à poser
cette question
un jour je prendrai la place publique
il veut qu'on vienne le chercher
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya sérieusement sur cette histoire de
tunisiens ont pas refaire l'histoire
mais une question que jamais personne ne
vous a posé c'était bien ces fameuses
vacances en tunisie qui vous obligé à
démissionner
à l'est pendant six ou sept ans quand
même michèle alliot marie ce qui est
bizarre c'est que vous voyez arriver là
la tentation totalitaire de la gauche
avait pas vu arriver la tentation
totalitaire de ben ali à la coque
écoutez on pourrait en parler c'est pas
ici où ça ça doit se faire ce qui lui
était reproché d'ailleurs c'était
beaucoup plus les malversations de la
famille de sa femme que qu'autres choses
quand vous discutez avec les tunisiens
voilà merci michèle alliot marie je
rappelle que le type de l'opinion la
tentation de qualité à la gauche c'est
chez plon et maintenant on passe à notre
look aux moeurs de la semaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
bérenger a créé un très bon soir
or
c'est vrai que s'appeler bérengère quand
on n'est pas une reine du moyen-âge
c'est un peu bizarre mais c'est vrai ça
vous va bien merci c'est très bien
déranger vous êtes comédienne humoriste
vous avez été révélée par la série bref
vous vous étiez marla le plan cul du
héros et tout vous appelez la fille
blonde de bresse
il ya plein de noms à un
plan cul la dame de bref voilà madame
alors vous n'êtes ni le 16 avril 1983 à
lyon vous commencez le théâtre neuf ans
et là vous découvrez votre vraie
vocation
vous étiez un peu le clown de la famille
quoi c'était dans ma personnalité de
faire rire quoi je limitais des gens
bien bérengère refait machin là donc moi
je le faisais ça me faisait rire les
gens rigolent je suis bien alors après
l'aqtim studio à lyon et l'école de one
man show à paris une école près de
l'école de one man show gaspard proust
appelle à ce que les professionnels
écoles finalement vous montez sur scène
en 2009 et c'est là que vous rencontrez
le mec de brefs kyan khojandi on faisait
des sketches dans un
café-théâtre pizzeria et puis cannes
avec
bruno muschio décide de faire bref merci
d après je sais pas à quel moment ils
sont dix bérengère ça sera le plan cul
régulier ça je sais pas comment mais bon
en tout cas ils m'ont appelé pour le
rôle mais vous avez eu raison
[Applaudissements]
alors
dérangère vous dis je me fait pas rire
je suis marrante et c'est vrai vous avez
les funny bones c'est à dire des gens
puis maintenant qu'ils vous font rire
comme sammy davis quand vous les voyez
c'est vrai en fait j'ai fait un surtout
un cours de théâtre pendant très
longtemps quand tu te tuer et moi
allions et un jour les filles on avait
15 ans on commence à être un peu des
dames elles disent on n'a qu'à faire un
truc pas marrant une un drame elle
apprendre dit ok on va faire la maison
de bernarda alba de federico garcia
lorca et on lit les textes pour savoir
qui va faire quoi alors moi je lis mon
texte et la prof et vers l'est bérengère
tu vas faire autre chose
dérange juillet au grand point virgule
et jean toute la france en février au
bataclan en avril à bobino et le 12 et
13 juin à l'olympia et en attendant on
regarde à quoi ça
alors du genre du genre le type tu
abordes tranquille il dit on fait un
tour de bagnols il croit que je vais
répondre quoi moi
hu
non mais attends mais c'est mon rêve
pas de faire une balade en opel corsa la
nuit avec 5 mais qu'est-ce que les 20
mai au sénat on y va
bah non
ah
non
c'est vrai que les femmes maurice amène
une vraie nouveauté dans le stand-up
parce qu'on commence à en avoir marre
des sketches sur les relations hommes
femmes et grâce à vous on est passé à
des sketchs relation femmes hommes
sans foi mieux il ya un truc que j'adore
qu'on va regarder c'est un truc vous
avez fait avec le golden shoe ça me fait
hurler de rire c'est le da vinci code
le mensonge un mensonge
les femmes n'ont jamais eu leur rêve
jamais
chéries chéris bébé
[Musique]
tu n'aurais jamais dû voir sa maman
qu'est ce qui se passe oui les règles
n'existent pas on a inventé des règles
depuis la nuit des temps c'est que je
parte qu'inventer les règles pour pas
couché avec césar parce que oui des fois
on n'a pas envie de baiser avec vous
alors on dit qu'on a une règle chez les
postes tandis que
les hommes dirigent le monde depuis des
siècles mais nous les femmes cinq jours
par mois on prend pouvoir cinq jours
pendant lesquels on a le droit d'être
désagréable et vous pouvez rien dire
parce que oui des fois vous nous saoulez
alors on dit qu'on aimerait
des fois on a envie d'aller à la piscine
alors on dit qu'on à leurs règles des
fois on a juste envie de dire comme à
nos règles
ça ne nous il savoir cette vertu et
d'amour où ça voilà alors
les sketchs le sketch continuer mais je
vous laisse découvrir la suite sur
internet parce qu'après ça prend des
proportions absolument à lui si nantes
[Musique]
alors bérengère vous ne serez pas étonné
que je vous fasse une interview le pire
de bérengère
alors la pire phrase qu'on est utilisé
pour vous aborder dans la rue
ainsi une fois il ya un mec qui m'a dit
un mademoiselle franchement vous avez
trop des belles dents
quel est le projet
le pire mac à côté duquel vous soyez
réveiller
stéphane bertrand on le connaissait non
voilà
je ne regarde
[Applaudissements]
alors
la pire célébrités qui a essayé de
draguer avant aujourd'hui
pas de casse bas par nagui une fois le
nom je me suis fait breaké une fois par
un sosie de pascal obispo la pire
imitation vous savez faire
j'en ai deux accords du là mais ça c'est
pas la pire ça c'est la mieux ça c'est
ma chérie tout et on perd c'est top
c'est super tu ris je t'adore tu es beau
tu es tout en noir c'est la classe
[Applaudissements]
les pyrales et y en ait deux jets
mitterrand et brigitte bardot fait
mitterrand au pouvoir
[Applaudissements]
alors la pire chose que vous ayez
accepté professionnellement
non une fois une fois j'ai joué dans un
salon pour 50 euros et après j'en ai
pour 58 euros de taxi
le pire inconvénients de la célébrité
alors je sais c'est ce jour où tu as les
cheveux gras retard sur le nez la tête
dans le fion théo franprix tu prends du
pq là y'a quelqu'un qui dit excusez moi
on peut faire une photo
et la pire humiliation que vous ayez
subi devant un mec ouais une fois oui
j'ai fait un
jeu rentre dans la chambre de vos mecs
j'ai fait un striptease de ouf pl je me
rends compte que je me suis trompée de
chambre
et ceci dit son père avait pas l'air de
[Applaudissements]
nos pires compliment qu'un homme puisse
vous faire
franchement ça va tu es pas grosse
la pire expérience sexuelle de votre vie
c'est quand mon mec a demandé un plan à
trois que j'étais pas dedans et qui
avait pas de fille
[Applaudissements]
et on passe maintenant à l'actualité de
la terre avec l'au-delà tôt c'est le
député socialiste carlos da silva que
nous retrouverons sur ce plateau après
le magnet tout ce soir nous poserons la
question et si valls finissait par
arriver
[Musique]
en 2011 lors de la primaire socialiste
manuel valls n'a recueilli que 5 % des
voix c'est parce que je suis de gauche
aujourd'hui pourtant il est devenu chef
la majorité
il en déduire que manuel valls avait
raison ça veut pas dire que 95% des
socialistes ont tout faux en effet selon
manuel valls le socialisme est une idée
complètement dépassés pense que le mot
socialiste nous enferme sans fil topi
est né au xixème siècle était là pour
renverser le capitalisme aujourd'hui
nous acceptons l'économie de marché mais
si valls est contesté au sein du ps au
niveau européen ça fait déjà un bon bout
de temps que le vieux socialisme à la
française n'a plus la cote on l'a déjà
15 ans que tony blair et gerhard
schröder ont signé un texte commun pour
affirmer que la gauche moderne doit
imaginer une troisième voie dans leur
texte berre et schroeder souhaitait même
que les chefs d'entreprise soit
désormais considérés comme des
footballeurs vedettes ou les stars de la
chanson et du cinéma
aujourd'hui valls s'est rallié à cette
position j'aime l'entreprise
résultat toute une partie du ps crie au
scandale
nous on est socialiste on laissera pas
le parti socialiste au mas de ceux qui
considèrent qu'ils ne le sont pas faut
dire que blair et schroeder sont censés
être de gauche et pourtant il était cité
en exemple par jean françois copé
lorsqu'il était encore le chef de l'ump
soyez schröder lançant les réformes qui
ont permis à l'allemagne de sauver son
modèle social en renforçant sa
compétitivité soyez blair de son côté la
gauche française continue de défendre
les 35 heures alors que nous sommes le
seul pays au monde à avoir adopté ce
système
la gauche française continue de défendre
lle chef alors que nous sommes le seul
pays d'europe à maintenir cet impôt mais
à l'image de montebourg qui voulaient
arrêter la globalisation à lui tout seul
avec ses petits bras musclés la gauche
française reste persuadé d'avoir exemple
contre le monde entier résultat quand
manuel valls est à la rochelle il se
fait chahuter par les membres de son
propre parti
en revanche lorsqu'il est invité en
italie par matteo renzi il est applaudi
par les leaders de la gauche allemande
portugaise espagnole et néerlandaise
la sinistra est forte once d'or est
réputée et pointe dans sa corbeille
cabinet la gauche moderne considère
qu'il faut soutenir les entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent créer de l'emploi
favoriser la croissance et donc
permettre de réduire les déficits
publics en france une bonne partie des
députés socialistes rejettent cette
politique
pourtant il ya peu de chances qu'ils
votent contre manuel valls mardi
prochain à l'assemblée pas forcément ça
conduirait à une dissolution or en ce
moment quand on se retrouve au chômage
c'est pas facile de retrouver du boulot
[Musique]
c'est un but de bateaux milan l'image
que julien grave da silva bonsoir j'ai
député ps de l'essonne et vous n'êtes
pas un frondeur non alors cette semaine
on a choisi de se demander et si valls
finissez par y arriver je sais c'est
bizarre alors premièrement il va lui
arriver parce qu'il est fidèle à lui
même même s'il trahit les promesses de
hollande il est fidèle à lui-même balle
et il est fidèle à lui-même dans ses
discours comme vous dites il va arriver
y arriver il va arriver à quoi là il
nous a fait un très beau discours devant
les chefs d'entreprise ouais il va y
avoir de problème le premier ça va être
dans quelques mois le vote du budget le
deuxième c'est françois hollande et
valls il doit appliquer les directives
de françois hollande et quels sont les
directives de françois hollande
ça
alors il va y arriver parce que plus
personne ne croit aux postures radicales
des mammouths du ps probablement mais qu
un jour on lui reconnaîtra la vertu
d'avoir un peu dépoussiéré le parti
socialiste de ces vieilles chimères et
de son idéalisme ils sont ils vivent
dans un temps qui n'existe plus cette
évidence ceci dit ils continuent d'avoir
une influence extrêmement importantes y
compris à l'assemblée nationale en tous
les cas non mais c'est vrai qu'il fait
l'aggiornamento
nécessaire que tous les autres partis
socialistes européens ont fait ce roeder
blair et c'est un nom à son discours
ressemble plus aujourd'hui à h he had
air ou à plaire encore une fois le
discours maintenant j'attends des apps
je continue il va y arriver il va y
arriver parce qu'il sait trancher il
sait ce qu'il veut il sait trancher mais
en premier ministre ne tranche qu'avec
l'autorité du président hariri problème
bah oui mais non mais c'est pas le
problème parce qu'on peut pas dire d'un
côté françois hollande ne tranche pas et
quand il ya deux semaines qu'il demande
la démission qu'il accepte la démission
et qu'il renomme un gouvernement dans la
foulée dans l'heure qui suit qu'il ne
tranche pas françois hollande tranche
faille penche d'un côté et puis va
trancher le contraire le lendemain
[Applaudissements]
bon
autre argument foutu pour foutu autant
faire des réformes tient quitte à être
impopulaire autant que ce soit pour
faire avancer la france c'est vrai ça
sauf que les institutions prévoient
qu'il faut une majorité à l'assemblée
pour pouvoir poursuivre les réformes et
qu'il n'est pas certain à ce jour j
majorité il aura le vote de confiance
oui il y aura la majorité
comment peut-on imaginer que le groupe
majoritaire provoque une crise politique
d'ampleur bien alors dernière raison
pour laquelle il va y arriver il n'a pas
le choix
toute façon il est obligé de faire ce
que bruxelles lui dis donc autant faire
semblant que c'est lui qui a eu l'idée
non
non je vous croire et je crois que nous
sommes un état nation qui décident de
l'essentiel des politiques que nous
menons et c'est le cas les joueurs oui
je crois ça va sinon ça sert à rien d
l'ire des parlementaires bas très
sérieusement nous décidons de beaucoup
de choses et d'ailleurs vous verrez le
débat qui va y avoir précisément sur
l'arrière orientations de l'europe c'est
des pays qui vont mener d'autres qui ne
sont pas là il ya une souveraineté
nationale heureusement ce que je
constate malheureusement à à l'europe
depuis 20 ans c'est qu'on entend de
moins en moins la france j'ai vu avec
nicolas sarkozy ce qui se passait dans
son entente avec merkel où nous voyons
quand il y avait une crise concernant la
russie ça m'était 48 heures et il allait
voir lui poutine y avait suffisamment de
force et une arme est d'ailleurs
suffisamment forte pour qu'effectivement
on fasse attention je ne me contente pas
et de la même façon sur le plan
économique c'est exactement la même
chose il est vrai que aujourd'hui ne
respectant même ce pas notre engagement
à l'égard de l'europe nous ne sommes pas
considérés comme des gens sérieux ni
comme des gens qui comptent en europe
alors conclusion il va y arriver ou pas
valls elle est terrorisée elle ne
regarde et pourquoi ça tombe sur moi
il va y arriver ou pas je sais pas je
regarderai les guignols
[Applaudissements]
m'a dit d'y arriver moi je souhaite de
tout coeur que un gouvernement
élu démocratiquement en france il y
arrive qu'ils soient de droite ou qu'ils
soient de gauche mais tant que c'est la
démocratie qui passe et pas des extrêmes
carlos merci d'avoir été avec nous
maggie merci d'avoir avec nous c'était
la p2 de slc on se retrouve après la pub
avec le japon gaspard proust de notre
carrière samedi 20h ce soir lorraine
atteint de la maladie de chapeau contre
laquelle les stars du monde entier
récolte de l'argent en faisant le rail
maquette chanel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
installez terrienne oui bonsoir était
rien
nous sommes bien que tout se paie et les
chômeurs touchant terre toujours en
compagnie de michèle alliot marie
[Applaudissements]
christophe hondelatte
et d'aujourd'hui mon petit monde
nous accueillons notre terriens du
samedi 20 heures ce soir lorraine
bonsoir
alors tout l'été l'iceberg challenge a
inondé les réseaux sociaux le but
récolter des dons pour la recherche sur
la rsl à la sclérose latérale
amyotrophique
alias la maladie de charcot le problème
c'est que le message d'origine s'est
perdu en route
aujourd'hui les gens ne voient plus le
seau d'eau sur la tête et oublie le but
de l'opération qui est d'aider à la
recherche sur la maladie de charcot
lorraine vous nous raconterez à 20h ce
qu'est la maladie de charcot dans un
instant gaspard proust mais d'abord le
zapping
c'était le zapping et maintenant
j'accueille gaspard proust sport elle
est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean l'affront ouais quand tu te voile
sur 20 ans la maison raison parce que
c'est une semaine c'est plutôt joyeux en
ce moment ils arrivent ils arrivent des
très très belles choses dans ce pays les
français lisent
on les croit grincheux et méfiant mais
en fait il se passionne pour la
politique à l'amour et ça c'est chouette
ce un
bref sinon cette semaine qu'à un mot qui
revient tout le temps ces dissolutions
louis à ça ne vous en parle beaucoup on
parle plus va tout s'en sort sa
dissolution donc en plus de dissoudre
l'assemblée il faut dissoudre un député
en ce moment thomas thévenoud qui a fait
son coming out avec cette douloureuse
maladie la phobie administrative alors
on va quand même pas mettre au chômage
une personne malade
ballon d'or c'est une question de santé
publique imagine que cela soit
contagieux est-ce qu'on peut prendre le
risque de laisser ce mec filet dans la
nature
si tout le monde shop sa maladie plus
personne va payer ses loyers ses impôts
donc c'est
du coup évidemment tout le monde a
oublié le gouvernement valls 2 walser on
dirait un peu le nom d'un terminal
d'aéroport
c'est le
[Applaudissements]
ça fait un peu
c'est le hub des charters promovacances
lastminute
ce que ce gouvernement plus personne
n'en parle autant on sait tous ce qu'on
a fait le 11 septembre 2001 je pense que
dans 20 ans quand tu qui va demander à
son père papa tu faisais quoi le jour la
démission du gouvernement valls il va
répondre je sais pas je lisais le livre
de trio renner
alors il reste quand même des belles
images dans ce gouvernement quand même
quand on voit laurent fabius stéphane le
foll michel sapin qui marchent côte à
côte et devant eux najat vallaud
belkacem ne dirait on pas le remake de
trois hommes et un couffin
85% des français ne souhaitent pas que
hollande qui représente alors au point
où il en est c'est peut-être pas très
fair play de continuer de le mesurer
contre des personnes
s'en sont peut-être plus intéressant le
mesurer contre un des objets de la vie
quotidienne 1 à dire si demain avait
lieu le premier tour pour qui
voteriez-vous à pot de chambre une
cartouche d'imprimante françois hollande
ou une machine à raclette
dans l'hypothèse où françois se qualifie
pour le 2e tour quel serait le meilleur
candidat en face une boîte de cirage ou
un deltaplane
oui ça donnerait une indication
intéressante alors il a réagi quand même
très dignement la polémique descendants
et je dois dire que moi je ne méprise
pas laissant dans non dans l'intimité ce
sont elles qui de loin donne le plus de
plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors hollande viendra il en rajoute un
coup il déclare alors mon grand père
maternel petit tailleur d'origine
savoyarde mon grand père paternel
instituteur issu d'une famille de
paysans pauvres du nord de la france et
vous croyez que je pourrai mépriser le
milieu d'eux je tiens mes racines ma
raison de vivre est vraiment qu'est plus
que le passage je me souviens encore la
joie sur nos visages lorsque maman en
guise de dessert nous ramener le soir
les épluchures de pommes que les cochons
avait refusé de manger
c'était
7 et byzance comme nous disions c'était
notre manière à nous petits pauvres
d'oublier que on nous payer nos vacances
de camping ont fabriqué des prothèses
dentaires avec le cartilage de nos
hamster
je ne comprends pas ta le mec qui dit
les pauvres sont ma raison d'être bon à
ce niveau là c'est une réussite c'est
vrai qu'avec lui on a plus
[Applaudissements]
façon ya des choses plus importantes
comme le déficit public ça c est là
encore raté
la croissance n'est pas encore venu
[ __ ] la [ __ ] tu vois
elle a encore posé un lapin cette cct à
hollande il attendait sur le quai d'une
gare avec ses petites fleurs et un non
non je vais pas venir encore là ce que
lui son truc c'est l'économie c'est
comme la météo c'est ainsi que tôt ou
tard après la pluie vient le beau temps
non
non après la pluie vient le crachin
après le crachin bien la giboulée après
la giboulée vient la grêle après la
grêle vient la bourrasque fois ses
essais ses 50 nuance de pluie je pense
moi
[Applaudissements]
gaza
alors alors bien entendu en tant
qu'observateur comme ça de la vie
publique
on entend partout ça favorise qu'il a
montée du front national
alors je me disais si marine le pen
devient président parce que c'est l'idée
qu'on nous vend bon moi je commente jeu
commun c'est crédible après monsieur
tout le monde pourquoi pas madame
n'importe quoi un peu oui
on va faire des trucs incroyables va
dissoudre l'assemblée elle va sortir de
l'euro et va doubler le smic baisser les
loyers augmenter le débit de la loire a
botté le mont-blanc
enregistrer un disque avec jimi hendrix
[Applaudissements]
admettons amis mais ce qui m'intéresse
c'est bon si elle devient présidente
elle n'est pas mariée
donc son mec quand elle va arriver au
point et veulent quitter est-ce que lui
va se venger est-ce qu'il va écrire un
livre
après merci pour ce moment danke schön
fera au lime für das momen
bon bonne nouvelle quand même 13 %
d'opinions favorables
pour françois alors en fait c'est 12
parce que 1 % déclarent qui lui fait
tout à fait confiance ce qui veut dire
que quand même où personne sur 100 en
france qui est un [ __ ] de sens de
l'ironie
pour ça c'était la bonne nouvelle et
j'en ai une autre commune est dans la
lignée des icebergs est alors dans la
lignée de l'iceberg et moi aussi moi
aussi je m'engage je j'ai ramené mon
saut je propose le fisc beuquette
challenge donc chacun ce verre sur la
tête ce qui lui reste après le passage
du fisc
alors évidemment je nominal arthur
bernard arnault et yannick noah pour les
prochaines
voilà c'est pas bientôt
alors in the fight night bonheur
mais d'ici à demain sur canalplus.fr
grano gaspard on passe maintenant à
notre terrain du samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
lauren robb bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
jack né à paris le 8 août 1962 après le
lycée ou fait des études à l'école
supérieure de commerce et très vite vous
décrocher des postes à responsabilité
dans des grandes compagnies
multinationales et là vous travaillé 12
heures par jour et vous voyagez sans
arrêt vous êtes une femme extrêmement
active et même pendant les vacances vous
apprenez à piloter un avion de tourisme
revis deux pilotes effectivement et en
plus excellente danseuse de rock am une
passion depuis toujours la danse ouais
alors cette formidable énergie est
entretenu par une hygiène de vie
impeccable une coupe de champagne à noël
aussi à mon anniversaire et puis un jour
de l'été 2011 vous n'arrivez pas à
ouvrir une pince à linge avec la main
gauche parce que vous êtes gauchère dont
vous le faites avec la main droite
où vous dis c'est pas grave quelques
jours plus tard un verre vous glisse des
mains ou vous dis c'est pas grave
quelques semaines plus tard vous fait
une chute dans la rue et vous vous dites
ça doit être les talons où il devait y
avoir une bosse sur le trottoir et puis
ces petits symptômes anodin se
multiplient vous avez des crampes et
vous avez des spasmes musculaires
petite vibration sous la peau il faudra
attendre six mois avant que vous alliez
voir un généraliste qui vous oriente
vers un neurologue à l'hôpital de la
pitié salpêtrière
et un mois plus tard le diagnostic tombe
et c'est la sclérose latérale
amyotrophique
la maladie de charcot et là vous dites
c'est un seau d'eau glacée qui m'est
tombé sur la tête d'abord j'étais
totalement stupéfait puisque je passais
d'une situation jeu j'étais quelqu'un
qui considère est en très bonne santé et
en une seconde j'ai découvert ce que
c'était quatre malades et je ne
connaissais pas du tout cette
maladie
après renseignement j'ai découvert
qu'elle était
dramatique alors là le verdict
effectivement c'est la triple peine
d'abord vous avez entre 3 et 5 ans
d'espérance de vie vous disent les
médecins
deuxième sanction la salle a est une
maladie dégénérative ça veut dire
qu'elle ne s'arrête jamais petit à petit
elle paralyse tous les muscles du corps
d'abord les fonctions motrices et puis
ensuite la déglutition et la respiration
troisièmement le handicap donc la
dépendance faut toujours quelqu'un pour
s'occuper de vous là pendant plusieurs
semaines c'est l'abattement total
oui complémentaire très grande désespoir
parce que je suis quelqu'un comme tous
les malades qui aimons avoir une
solution est en fait à ce moment là est
d'ailleurs encore maintenant
nous n'avons pas de solutions auxquelles
nous raccrocher donc ça c'était un
moment très très difficile
et là vous avez une vision vous fait un
rêve éveillé on peut dire et vous voyez
une équipe qui vous aide dans cette
épreuve
assez vite j'ai imaginé que je n'y
arriverai pas tout seul donc j'ai
imaginé que d'autres médecins d'autres
personnes avec des compétences
même différente de la médecine serait à
mes côtés pour m'aider à
confronter la maladie parce qu'en fait
c'est à la fois faire avec puisqu'elle
est là et lutter contre
cette croyante
je le deviens oui et ça aide alors vous
vous dites à ce moment là il faut que je
reprenne ma vie en main malgré tout et
si ça doit être court au moins que ce
soit beau
dans un premier temps où la jouer classe
vous snobé la can vous prenez un
parapluie c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup
plus élégant d'avoir un parent a plus qu
une qualité très joliment part à petit
bientôt ce sont les béquilles et bientôt
encore le fauteuil roulant et là vous
dépendez des autres tu faisais besoin
qu'on s'occupe de vous êtes bien
d'auxiliaire de vie évidemment pour
votre toilette pour votre habillement
pour la pour la cuisine les repas vous
faire manger d'une certaine façon
même votre brosse à dents c'est à dire
qu'on vous met le dentifrice sur la
brosse électrique et vous la tenez avec
les deux mains c'est ça je la tiens en
fête avec mes deux poignées parce que
mes doigts
non plus de force hélas ce qui est
extraordinaire si vous vous engagez dans
le financement de la recherche sur la sl
à la business woman que vous êtes
organise un gala caritative et vous
récoltez 120000 euros ce qui est
beaucoup d'un seul coup vous arrivez à à
utiliser ce que vous savez faire ce que
vous êtes
pour lutter contre votre maladie c'est
assez beau ça en fait j'étais des
ressources et puis cette maladie ne
touche pas le cerveau oui enfin les
capacités intellectuelles si vous voulez
donc j'ai voulu mettre mes compétences
qui étaient en métiers des ressources
humaines et surtout de la communication
au profit de la mallet qui me touchent
et touche un grand nombre de personnes
alors là vous rencontrez clémentine
célarié et thierry monfreid qui sont en
train de monter un spectacle de danse
qui s'appelle la danse immobile et
quelques mois plus tard vous vous
retrouvez sur la scène du du festival
d'avignon oui clémentine et thierry
m'ont parlé de leur projet et ce
spectacle pour moi tout de suite
réveiller
le goût de la danse ouais et
c'est comme ça que je suis rentré dans
le spectacle avec un rôle effectivement
festival d'avignon cet été le spectacle
continue toujours les gens peuvent
peuvent aller le voir
il le 13 août dernier donc juste après
avignon vous découvrez l'ice beckett
challenge
[Musique]
jean
[Applaudissements]
alors
qu'aux états unis 100 millions de
dollars ont été récoltés en un mois et
le problème c'est qu'en traversant
l'atlantique le iceberg challenge a
perdu son sens parce que ici les gens
font plutôt ça faut le dire comme une
blague de potache en fait on peut faire
de la sbq challenge en mentionnant que
c'est au profit de la recherche cela et
c'est là en nominant trois personnes et
faire un don oui
ou ne pas choisir de ne pas faire de
facebook chat n'a jamais vraiment bon
bah oui alors vous cette maladie vous a
quand même apporté des choses c'est ça
qui est extraordinaire c'est à dire que
vous avez appris par exemple à évacuer
le superficiel effectivement c'est assez
le paradoxe de cette de l'arrivée de
cette maladie dans ma vie c'est que
ce que je faisais avant de me donnait
pas l'occasion de savourer chaque jour
chaque jour est un cadeau ce qu'il ait
gagné vous avez découvert la joie tout
simplement de la contemplation c'est à
dire de regarder le monde qui est beau
regarder quoi un lever de soleil je
regarde un lever de soleil je regarde à
coucher de soleil je regarde les nuages
dans la journée
la nature en général
et puis j'apprécie beaucoup les
rencontres que je fais les contacts que
j'ai avec mes nouvelles personnes aussi
vous avez dit juste je veux vivre le
plus longtemps possible
oui c'est tout le mal qu'on vous
souhaite lorraine
voilà c'était salut les terriens votre
photo du samedi avec jean-louis mon
petit jean mi
[Applaudissements]
merci à michèle alliot marie pour la
tentation totalitaire de la gauche chez
plon bérengère krief sur la scène du
grand point virgule entouré lance de la
fronde avec son spectacle merci
christophe hondelatte de retour si on
paye nagui tous les jours deux fois sur
france 2 et sur france inter à 11h05
pour la bande originale
carlos da silva et tout est ps de
l'essonne lorraine merci votre
témoignage
merci tous ceux qui m'ont aidé à faire
cette émission je vous laisse les colons
en est
la semaine prochaine et ici là sur
canalplus.fr salut les gars
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu de
bleu